صحيفه الموند علقت على مقتل بريكوجين
بالقول ان على المرء ان يكون مخلصا في
نظام بوتين او لا يكون ابدا وابرز
التوقعات خبراء بان تكون تداعيات نهايه
قائد مجموعه فاجنر على استقرار النظام
السياسي الروسي محدوده وقد تنحصر في
استياء مؤيديه المقربين داخل المجموعه ومن
تعاطفوا معه من الجيش النظامي حين خطط
لتنفيذ تمرده بالاضافه الى الدوائر
القوميه التي كانت تراه بطلا
نقرا في الواشنطن بوست بان موت بريجوجين
يلقي بظلال من الشك على مستقبل مجموعه
اذ لا يستبعد مراقبون انهيارها قريبا
والاستيلاء على جميع انشطتها خارج روسيا
من طرف مقربين من الكرملين الحادث كما
تقول الصحيفه يمثل بالنسبه لكثيرين وسط
النخب الروسيه اشاره الى اعاده تاكيد
بوتين بسيطرته وتسليطا للضوء على العواقب
التي قد يسوقها عدم الولاء داخل دوله
استبداديه ولها تاريخ حافل بعمليات سجن
وقتل وتسميم منتقدي الرئيس واعداءه
صحيفه الجاردن ترى ان موت بريجين سيساعد
في تهدئه الغضب بين كبار الضباط داخل
الجيش الروسي ومعهم وزير الدفاع ونقلت عن
مصدر مقرب من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه القول
ان قتل بريجوجين يمثل عامل استقرار قويا
للنظام الحالي وللمزاج السائد في الجيش
اما عن انشطه فاجنر في افريقيا فترجح
الصحيفه ان يحاول الكرملين او وزاره
الدفاع استغلال صفقاتها المربحه هناك
راى مقال بصحيفه التايمز ان الخطوه الاولى
التي قام بها بوتين بعد تمرد المجموعه هي
اخضاعها لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه ثم تلتها
عمليه تطهير هادئه لكبار الضباط ليس فقط
من اظهروا تعاطفا بسيطا مع اقدامى
المحاربين في فاجنر بل ايضا اولئك الذين
شاركوا شكاوى العلنيه بشان اداره الحرب في
اوكرانيا ويرى المقال ان احد اسباب بقاء
مجموعه فاجنر هو القاء اللوم على عناصرها
في ارتكاب الفضائع والجرائم في اوكرانيا
والحفاظ على سمعه الجيش الروسي النظامي
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز قالت ان الاستنتاج
الذي يفرض نفسه بعد موت بريجين هو ان مصير
قائد فاجنر قد حسم قبل شهرين ومن المؤكد
ان جيش بوتين من المتملقين والاصدقاء
يفهمون الرساله الان جيدا مضيفا ان
الخيانه في روسيا بوتين جريمه لا تغتفر
وهذا يعني ان الحاجه الى اثبات الولاء
الشخصي اصبحت اكثر اهميه في ظل حرب
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]